>> Bret: THE LAWYER SAYS THAT
THE FIGHT WAS A SELF-DEFENSE
SITUATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS BECOME PART
OF WHAT HE CALLS THE RADICAL
LEFT DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THE PRESIDENT'S LATEST TWEETS,
AS HE FENDS OFF ALLEGATIONS OF
RACISM OVER HIS CRITICISM OF A
GROUP OF PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS WOMEN.
TONIGHT WE TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
THE MEDIA IS COVERING THE
CONTROVERSY ALL WEEK LONG.
HERE IS MEDIA ANALYST AND HOST
OF MEDIA BUZZ HOWARD KURTZ.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WAS
NOT HAPPY THAT SOME AT THE
NORTH CAROLINA CHANTING ABOUT
ILHAN OMAR, THE SOMALI BORN
CONGRESSWOMAN WHO HE WAS
CRITICIZING ALONG WITH THREE
OTHER FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT UNLOADED ON THE
PRESS TODAY TWEETING IT IS
AMAZING HOW THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA
BECAME CRAZED OVER THE CHANT
SEND HER BACK.
BUT IS TOTALLY CALM AND
ACCEPTING OF THE MOST VILE AND
DISGUSTING STATEMENTS MADE BY
THE THREE RADICAL LEFT
CONGRESSWOMEN.
THAT THEIR MOVEMENT NOW INCLUDES
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
BUT EVEN PRO-TRUMP COMMENTATORS
LIKE PIERS MORGAN DENOUNCED THE
CHANCE AS SHAMEFUL AND RACIST.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
STARTED SPEAKING RIGHT AWAY, HE
ACTUALLY PAUSED DURING THE CHANT
FOR 13 SECONDS.
TRUMP DECLINED THE RALLY GOERS.
HE ALSO RIPPED
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" COLUMNIST
WHO ACCUSED HIM OF RACISM SAYING
THOMAS THE CHAIN FREE FRIEDMAN
REALLY NASTY TO ME IN HIS
AVERAGE IQ COLUMNS, BUT KISS MY.
HE SAYS HE IS RESPECTFUL TOWARDS
PEOPLE HE DISAGREES WITH, AND
TRUMP SHOULD TRY THAT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND OTHER
OUTLETS ARE BRANDING HIS TWEETS
SAYING THAT CONGRESSWOMEN SHOULD
GO BACK TO WHERE THEY COME FROM
AS OF RACIST.
>> FOUR DEMOCRATIC WOMEN OF
COLOR HAVE SPOKEN PUBLICLY ABOUT
THE RACIST TWEETS AIMED AT THEM
BY THE PRESIDENT ON THE
UNITED STATES.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SPARKED A
STORM OF OUTRAGE AFTER A SERIES
OF RACIST TWEETS TARGETING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DENYING THAT
HIS RACIST TWEETS WERE RACIST.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN WIDELY PANNED
AS RACIST EVEN THOUGH HE DENIES
IT, BUT IF IT IS THAT OBVIOUS,